[Music]
all right how's everybody doing welcome
to the basement with Danish and O'Neill
yeah we haven't even in here from
Houston that's a random question
houstonians whoa crazy got lucky on that
one
h-town in the house zip that scissor you
guys know what the deal is we're just
gonna dig right in start our first video
this one's a barn burner and all my
friends are doing we are selling our
used panties it's a lot of a lot of
numbers being flashed on screen I don't
even know what's happening why does this
look like a old navy and by the way I'm
doing it my friends are doing maybe they
just bought it from Old Navy when they
were doing like racier ads in the 90s
was this redubbed it you're selling
dirty panties I think I'm doing it
everybody all my friends are doing okay
you need a new circle of friends if it's
like a you selling your panties oh you
are too we're all selling our panties my
mom's selling her panties now what what
70 bucks are left ass cheek sweater your
ass cheek looks like her knee is getting
$420 it says my Ernie
oh she's earned $420 nobody bears a pan
maybe she's been doing this two years
that's not a very good return my mom
actually was one of the first women
doing this she's a founding ya founding
member of the panty trade one of the
four mothers
if you go come out Rushmore of panty
sales you'll see my mom's face hopefully
she doesn't watch this by the way this
is shocking how how this video is is
being basically targeted to children I
would say more or less and why do you
say children I mean it has that like fun
feel of like back-to-school sale because
they're just trying to be fun and
everyone's selling their panties who's
not having a good time oh I can see like
a kid watching this would be like I feel
terrible because I just put my dirty
underwear in the hamper they were making
money they made $420 leaving people
working at dry cleaners are like look at
all this [ __ ] money we're way it's
insane like why are you watching it
let's just sell it say we lost every
time you go to the dry cleaners and your
panties are gone they're selling a bob
line I'm wearing panties right now and I
might sell them to the audience after
the show you got to make sure they're
really stunk up good yeah I'm sweating
let me smell it first I'm wearing a
sweater and these pants don't breathe at
all do they have quality control at this
place do they have a guy who just smells
up neither guys put them in the package
these are good to go I think it's kind
of you run your own business but you
would hope some go for your own box
that's another fun aspect is you're in
charge let's hit planes you've got other
great things we can learn nothing says
safe like the panty trade also like what
what is the danger there like it's not
like those other businesses where people
kick your door in and steal all your
dirty Mandy but I cannot see someone
being naive and putting their like
return address on a package and you have
some creep who's like I want to smell
those panties myself I would I like the
lady who's like the little bit nasty
woman who's in the bikini on the bed it
was also very playful about the lady in
the bikini yeah who's like she's like
Jake look they're like is there a piece
that extra money if you're like Trant is
a transgenders like adding toppings to a
piece if they're like okay yeah I'll
take a little I guess it is you find out
the true market value of your genitals
yeah yeah you like let's see what I'm
working I somehow lost $10 and that
girl's cheek is worth 70 let's see more
up more about safety
join my life with all of my senses I
taste
I feel I see my smell especially the
scent of women inspires they're saying
that the average consumer of these
panties is some sophisticated wide
tasting guy some [ __ ] pervert and
living in his basement not unlike this a
lot of perverts do you love to walk
through field touching the eye like this
guys having sex with a real woman but he
stills like I still would have sniffed
those panties when he's at work he puts
it on like an oxygen mask he should have
done it right there while he's doing it
I see I feel what are you saying the
smell of a woman's perspiration nobody
said I don't know if that's what you're
smelling in those panties perspiration
aspiration yeah I don't the swelling of
the wife it's just a real topper for me
I love wine and I love the smell of
women's used panties what it made you
feel better he was drinking wine out of
a box directly yeah
20 panties over his head just like
smoking crack like okay that's the real
connoisseur of these panties just openly
weeping perusing the internet wiping his
tears wiping lasagna off of his chin
with those news panties I like that they
show you the consumer and the same ad
they're like oh you don't think people
are buying it look at this guy he's
buying them I'm surprised they use the
same ad where they're like and all of
his friends buy panties too I'm doing it
so is my dad alright let's get back to
it
what about the beads marijuana to
someone who lost a job pani deal
so that is pani deals like a real
website where you can buy use panties
but this is a recruitment video that
they put out and be honest with you I
also worked for me yeah I'm a hundred
percent on board with this I'm soon as
we get out of here I'm hopping on my
phone getting on pani deal but now let's
hear now we've seen the let's say
corporate side of it that could be bias
you know obviously you're trying to sell
us a product let's hear from somebody
doing it who looks like she's dead in
the eyes already hey girls I'm going to
make a short video talking about prices
so first of all you have no idea what
I'm talking about then here's a quick
explanation posit real quick can't teach
charisma like that she's just popping
off the screen you gotta be bored with
it why isn't she come to Hollywood an
act well I sell your panties when you
got that talent I'm gonna make a short
video
this is pani feel calm behind her with a
gun calm actual guys this [ __ ] video
to make the video or your whole family
dies it seems like I have to sell all
these panties cuz my brother's been
kidnapped
we need to raise enough money to get him
back save this lady like in five years
from now is like I regret doing that I
want to become a teacher like she's no
she's done like your own pani deal calm
coating selling your pants drink me so
what it's gonna go out cup a teacher at
some point well I have faith in calm is
the biggest and you get the best portal
to use to sell your underwear and buyers
from all over the world will pay good
cash to get your undies and also your
bras your socks and pretty much anything
that you wear in your body it's quick
and easy cash and also a lot of funds so
that's what it is
now power subject this is the best take
they had of this lady doing this you can
barely get through it
what is this fun angle I don't
understand oh my god Janice did you see
how much this creepy dudes bidding all
my panties what's more fun than selling
something you don't really care you're
making money off these panties yeah
about this how capitalistic is our
society becoming like we sell our dirty
undies as well basically anything socks
yeah SKU tips I assume yeah I buy those
yeah anything you wear on your body
about like ah those oxys it pads I bet
they'll buy those you buy she said bras
socks and panties that the Holy Trinity
like the big three I think it is do they
have like a food pyramid of like
articles of clothing that you can sell
yeah the yarmulkes is very low on the
totem yeah scarfs and mittens are very
low alright let's go back to miss
personality when selling your on these
it could be a bit confusing at first and
also kind of hard to decide a price that
you want to put on them I know that I
had trouble deciding and I saw someone
these four five some 450
and even 14 they just kept getting hires
so which one am I and how do I pick it's
so easy way to how much swamp ass you
have basically the price I don't get why
she says it's confusing cuz I think all
these people went to business school
right all Harvard grads can't you just
look at a pair and be like oh that's a
$40 we're looking for five I think that
the actual price of underwear is more
than five dollars a total loser that's
how the term low-balling came about
let's get back to this to do it is to
first start off with the price of undies
that you are about to sell if they are
highly balking at four well the guy with
the gun have a brand on them then the
press could go up for sure so also if
they are cheap on these and you can
probably settle for less and second
thing is considered how attractive can
you present them I put like a little
parsley on top it's about plating yeah
do you eat with your eyes okay okay yes
some chips where do you put like a face
on it that's waving at people all the
googly eyes yeah be cool we're like yeah
like some sort of uh like really dress
it up like put a bedazzler on it if
they're like crotchless you could use
that as like a mouth and put eyes above
panties and make them look anything
other than they are you're like you see
these [ __ ] streaks we're gonna dress
those up that's that's patina alright go
back to this weirdo also if they don't
look so good then you obviously want a
southern for less or depending on how
you present them and also what you need
to know is that the buyers individually
you want underwears to be worn for
different time periods
and also have them like just a different
sense or anything that you can pretty
much imagine so also if you end up doing
these I think you could bump up your
price higher and at the end of the day
it's just pleasing the customers and
also not understanding yourself because
you can always just make more money so
yeah our next field be about okay right
Jesus you seem so so depressed I would
like to buy a 5 a 15 and a 40 and then
really see what the difference is just
like constantly I will do it blind
smells oh can you see actually you tell
cheap panties it's like expensive wine
versus the cheap wine yeah bring it back
to the guy that's willing it that sales
pitch the Japanese are doing vending
machines with panties and we're step
behind we're still mailing them but
actually here's the thing that they're
not telling you about the used panty
industry we actually did a deep dive and
one undercover and met somebody who is
going to blow the doors off of this
industry and I think it's gonna be a big
story and you're getting exclusive scoop
from the basement right here let's play
that video it's an 80 billion dollar a
year industry and it's just getting
started that's right we're talking about
used panties they're selling like
hotcakes
but they sure don't smell like them meet
Elaine she's an airline pilot who got
into selling her soiled panties as a
side hustle a few years ago would you
say it affects your day job at all no
actually the complete opposite like
honestly I'm an airline pilot
long flight you could really work up
some nice swamp-ass I was on this other
flight from Beijing to LA these are
brand-new going on the market today
Monica Lee for sale we're on the tarmac
for four hours no bathroom breaks Wow
unfortunately not all sellers are as
honest and hardworking as Elaine there's
some scammers out there and they are
trying to destroy the integrity of this
beautiful industry she's talking about
painting mills meet Lisa Johnson she's
the hottest used panty seller in the
world but some say she's soiling the
dirty panty industry's good reputation
we've obtained shocking undercover
footage from a disgruntled employee what
we've uncovered could leave a permanent
stain with the law anymore I had to come
clean this is Erin it's not his real
name his real name is Michael but he
wanted us to hide his identity because
he feared retaliation from Miss Johnson
he worked for her for eight years
I got real sweaty hog that's what got me
in the game some of her smelly repairs
payments went for 150 200 bucks I got
paid minimum wage she's a real monster
that's why they get out I cut that good
we caught up with miss Johnson to get to
the bottom of this stinky situation it's
the right address
get her here you got to keep up with me
don't sprain your ankle like you do the
chili cook-off you can't [ __ ] this one
up ratings
[ __ ] that's right well how do you answer
this footage I have bigger differences
taken by an ex-employee of yours was it
my cloth yes what no no no is a hard
like when you say to all the men and
women maybe not the women that you've
misled one more person one more question
miss Johnson is does it please
yes that's how you do it Gary whoo yes
the next time you think about buying
yourself some soiled panties you're
probably gonna want to think twice cuz
your hard-earned money maybe just go
into a panty man oh and those the real
deal they sure smell like it we may just
never know wow thank you that's a real
thing
folks there's a real thing all right
let's move on from panty sales I know a
lot of you guys would like to stay on
panty sales for a while yeah I see a lot
of hands raised your questions for the
end you're like where are the
commercials with Asian men breastfeeding
their child well you're in for a treat
we have one right here uh so let's go to
our next video yeah uh there we go
this is a product I didn't got at Japan
[Music]
babies in Japan sleep less on average
than infants in any other country how do
I know that father's struggle to do
their best to remedy this situation but
things don't always work out are you
reading the subtitles line yeah yeah
that's why we invented something to help
dads help their babies guys so sad
awesome a device to help fathers
introducing the nursing assistant
nursing infants and putting them to bed
have always been areas of particular
difficulty for many men in the world of
child-rearing wait stop that's free free
from this screen screen what is dandling
and playing
what is Dandeli do you think that that
was just a language which it sounds like
molesting but I don't know also why are
they sleeping less than other countries
oh you know why I think it's from the
street yelling hi-yah I do not support
that but I don't understand this graph
really do you dandling is very often
play almost as often so this is what
dads are willing to do but nursing isn't
even that but they can nurse this is
their sake metal like almost 40% of men
are like Oh Albert um there's the baby
yeah and they're like with what he's
like good point that's your we come in
yeah
stop dandling and start nursing I like
oh only 30% will put them to sleep it
seems like every dad will be like I'll
put the kid to sleep but especially if
you're worse it kind of goes handed yeah
let's get the kid to sleep so we can do
it well new moms may not want it but
okay yeah we made the ultimate breast
device to help fathers give the gift of
a good night's sleep to their babies
with a great drawing the device boasts a
stylish shape that conforms to the
infant's body has a natural texture and
is also heated to simulate the
comforting body temperature of the
mother all of which are optimal for
reducing asleep at the level of milk is
also visually displayed and the data can
be saved acted real beige to the
child-rearing process
[Music]
leave it to me now why are they speaking
Japanese ahead of us and telepathic
communicator child in English every time
either him or the woman they all they
hold the baby like this they like yeah
they're so scared of it that's called
dangling oh now what it is for you to
hold them like this each dandle it at
arm's reach yeah uh so right now this
baby that should have been daddy
question mark you're about to breastfeed
me blow in my mind no this baby knows
you think the baby's like give me give
me the dad milk you imagine being
related to somebody so smart they could
invent something and this is the
invention they choose whether you guys
think you magically related the people
in this video well I am really oh you
had to choose the male breastfeeding
gasps you've ever met the Japanese side
of my family tree this guy the whole
time I looked every time I look at this
guy think that it is a woman and then I
have to remind myself that it's because
of the TV that again also the drawing of
the titties looks like a elementary
school kids at home why only one nipple
what if you want to switch I I don't
think they're that far I think you got
to wait for the second version of it
like 2.0 titty dad titty feedin and not
known of that what they call it titty
feed
yeah that's what they called in the
south that's the technical term no
offense at Houston like a lot not to get
into the panty sales area but a lot of
breastfeeding is sent and so like it's
not like rubbing or be hold on to this
guy's fake titty maybe the mom wears it
goes to the gym works out then gives it
to the day it's something new do you
double tits huh yeah what if you're a
man that doesn't feel like he has like
the tits are big enough do they sell
larger sizes well what if you already
have like man tits and you have to put
this on over it it's like a glove all
right let's see what happens to this
telepathic communication here
[Music]
technology has given there if you're
saving everywhere
this guy's Japan's biggest actor the
Brad Pitt of Japan rigid Brad Pitt in
America doing an ad for a male breast
feeding device he's watching you just
gave him an idea I feel like why do we
all have to get in on everything I don't
get it my babies 15 months old and I've
never once been like god I wish I could
have a nipple this baby's mouth and I
give her a bottle and it's not much
different than that and you feel
connected yeah or I do either you do
duct tape to the bottle to your nipples
yeah I do just so they're coming right
out yeah sometimes I do the gallon and
just like you got to get used to a
bigger container I almost drowned her I
mean I want to follow these kids
I just want to see what the overall
effect is long-term just when the drug
abuse starts in the last bike like who
breastfed you well mostly my dad did oh
that product that was banned a year
later for trauma also what if is it
legal then for the dad to breastfeed
kids tell their teenagers like it's not
as creepy I guess could the dad
breastfeed the mother and sin sexually
tells me that it's always gonna turn
into sexual especially in Japan yeah
there's any culture that's more
perverted than in the u.s. it's Japan I
don't think I could ever use this
because I'd just be squirting my wife I
just be spraying her all the time like
you don't need it on all the time the
baby this
you look is there something in this
nipple and effect through the old the
old on flower on the lapel with water
scootergal would you wear it to the
beach I would wear it to the beach
without kids that I'd be like would you
like me to nurse your children is that a
White Russian you're drinking sign it be
like who wants a French breast milk
White Russians you could set up like a
lemonade stand but you just pour milk
from this container I'm gonna get a lake
the local neighborhood kid to take over
the stand when you want to go inside if
this was in the US how quickly would
people put alcohol in there and be like
tailgating sucking these fake titties
the number one seller would be like frat
guys at the path of a parking lot yeah
everybody would be like you know so gone
by like why are we drinking at a flask
when there are titty containers now oh I
mean I would actually use this to go to
a bar to save money I would just put it
under my shirt and just like reach that
me never search your breasts if you're a
man they search mine all the time
[Laughter]
why is my top off to get into this bar
like everyone's doing it dude I I would
totally do this now I'm poor this deal
not for breastfeeding babies this is not
what this is meant for this is
definitely meant for smuggling alcohol
would you rather sell use panties or
wear this device or do both at the same
time I would love to breastfeed a baby
whoops I like my panties but dreams a
bucket list of mine that's actually
would increase them because you could
probably have breast milk on the undies
rippen tripping it
what have you take the panties and wipe
the baby's Mohawk
they're not you didn't wear them maybe
that like before
maybe that's dandling
all right let's move on I think we've
all had enough of this dude
breastfeeding this child you can watch
it at home later let's get to the sauce
weatherman freaked out on this guy's
trying to tell people about serious
business and people just aren't having
it let's take a look here look this
heavy rain is between you and the
tornado that's why this is a dangerous
situation tonight it's dark it's also
rainy off social media we have viewers
complaining already just go back to the
show
no we're not going back to the show
folks this is a dangerous situation
it's nice right think about that this
was your neighborhood I'm sick and tired
this is like a substitute teacher you
get the he's [ __ ] lost [ __ ] I would
love to sit in life and be like [ __ ]
he's like this is he's been treatment
about this he's like finally like I have
a use when he was a young guy and
meteorology school this is like this is
my time this guy delivers pizza
part-time to because there's no way we
did a video on a past episode I think it
was on Russian cable access so you guys
keep may not see it yeah but he looks
like also a he looks like Dave from Pawn
Stars
[Laughter]
look at him squeezing it fancy so fancy
I'm sick of this [ __ ]
I don't go to here to school for you to
help to go back to the bachelor how much
school he is there I like to know how to
read the [ __ ] map I think it's nights
like night class like a half a year I
love if I wish I was in that town I
would be going like crazy perfect go
back to the bachelor yeah I think he's
opening himself it's not my neighborhood
I don't live in Ohio
go back to the bachelor let's watch more
of his freak out planning about this our
job here is to keep people safe and that
is what we're gonna do so I'm even
complain that this is all about my ego
stop okay
it definitely is about a V you go five
minutes to think about everybody knows
that the people with the biggest egos in
the entertainment business are the
weatherman yeah by far the hardest to
deal with and I like how he said our job
is to keep you safe jobs to get [ __ ]
ratings everybody has a smartphone I
don't need the weatherman he's uh he's
old these dogs he friends over he's
preaching to like ninety year old women
who are watching watching this at home
they're also there's like those nine
year old women that end up having like
these huge crushes on the weatherman
like LA has dallas raines
who's a guy he has his hair always like
slicked back stud yeah this guy that
does seem like a pretty dangerous
situation no I think his personality
what he's feeling emotions the red is
his anger a lot of I'm done with you
people I remember yeah that's pathetic
what does he mean by you people sit
dangerous situation here all right I'm
sorry I did that this is the person like
what are you doing we have people that
don't care about other people's safety
around here that's just ridiculous new
tornado warning here that's the same one
we had
it's headed toward central we've lost
Adrenaline's worn off he's losing his
yeah and he's realizing like I may be
fired for this about your fellow humans
well yeah that guy I don't know what
he's doing now I hope he's still
delivering the weather he's good at
staying in frame uh guys off screen the
whole time if I lived in this town I
would find out where he lived everybody
came out but she cut his grass I'd yell
hey [ __ ] you for root of The Bachelor
for me
I might move to this town to become the
new star weather mega this is my
competition yeah you know this you can
crush it in there you like guys we're
going right back to the bat I'm not
gonna lose my cool big [ __ ] let's
just go back I don't cares [ __ ]
tornadoes [ __ ] alright well that's the
weather man here and so what else oh we
have uh as you guys know cuz you watch
the show all the time
we like to bring in a new comedian and
introduce them to the world someone that
up-and-comer someone that we truly
believe in and this week our comedian is
once again he's been voted back Fang
Chow everybody watch the show all the
talk shows they usually have the
comedian address the crowd but the host
never get to enjoy it so now our little
take is that he will perform for us and
you guys don't get to enjoy it hold on
one second Shaolin get this thing fired
up because we don't have any camera
angles of you except this one you can
start Ronnie oh-ho Geoff Dennis Ryan
male tava hot John let's tell me you go
to them wait just pause it for one
second oh by the way it's all in
Mandarin go ahead sorry Geoff Dennis
shrug on you ha ha da sebum a on the
Murdoch time - well sure yeah yah yah
well that shows our Candia Ryan or neon
icon this year
wait homie I'm sorry tamo told us yeah
Ryan yeah yeah it's funny cuz it's
racist
yo EDM Jeff Orion Tai yasue Salman Khan
to Allah Banyan made a doll Susy diyaa
Jaguar not at all alright put it off H
I'm going yeah let's keep going we're
gonna go wash one element of our soul
our way of a wish or email well a bow
tie a bull roars I'm anti Dianna
Rio neo coach F Dennis
[Music]